it was just a lot of fun to be able to
play with three guys in spider-man suits
you kind of think well
getting three spider-man together
couldn't go one of two ways it was
powerful for me to be
working with andrew and tom and powerful
in a in a legitimately moving emotional
way three spider-mans reunite to discuss
the crossover event of the century i
honestly feel a little bit numb don't
worry tom the fans feel the same way all
three spider-man's unexpectedly showed
up in no way home and now the trio is
reflecting on their major cinematic
moment it was like oh the intention
feels very pure here it actually feels
like a great creative idea and a great
creative story it wasn't like they were
just asking us to come and say hi and
then leave again but actually
have us have our presence being in
service to tom to tom's journey and for
tom he was counting down the days until
the other spideys showed up on set the
date of
the other spidermans are coming was
etched on my calendar and i was getting
closer and closer and closer and you
know the closer and closer i got
the more and more nervous i was and then
as soon as i met you guys i realized i
had nothing to be nervous about but it
did get a little weird when everyone
suited up but i think it was really
strange and almost a little unfair how
they had us put the suits on and then
just jump around in front of a camera
together like that was one of the most
bizarre experiences of my life and from
day one it was a roller coaster that i
didn't want to get off the cast is well
versed in protecting marvel spoilers but
tom admits andrew got the worst of it
though andrew you because you were doing
press for months
there's a lot of chatter of the is he or
isn't he when it comes to the next
spider-man so let me just ask you so
like to be really clear how would i feel
hypothetically
if
my spider-man was put into the one
that's about to come out
how would i feel hypothetically if
so yeah no i definitely think i have
honest time in the end the spider-mans
of days past say they now have a unique
bond i think it's a testament to the to
these guys that it went it went the way
that it went which was a brotherhood i
was
just grateful every day i really it was
such a rich experience and as
the guys have touched on the kind of um
sharing of something and the the
brotherhood of it and that brotherhood
they formed on set is something andrew
went more into detail about with e.t the
fact that i get to be one of those
people wearing the suit next to
my actual spider-man hero toby maguire
and
the the brilliant incredibly talented
heartfelt funny good sweet
perfect spider-man of tom holland and
then i get to be the middle brother and
i get to be like in awe of my older
brother and in full longing to protect
my younger brother and just like and
also there's something spiritual that
that kind of happened and i found that
deeply moving mentorship like the theme
of mentorship and
and how these two people across the
universe were the only ones that could
really fully understand what this young
man was going through and that was
always that was really important to us
as well that was really about tom and
tom's character tom's peter tom's
journey
as them as the center that and we were
just there to kind of support and have a
lot of fun